well welcome thank you is this have you
been to Copenhagen before I have I came
when I was a child with my parents they
took me on a tour in Denmark really I
have a very warm feeling about Tivoli
and Legoland that's great
and the Little Mermaid so yeah that's
the only souvenir I have honestly but
yeah it was good
good then welcome back thank you yes I'm
very happy to be here we're flattered
that all of you came I really wonder
what I'm gonna say well I mean we're
gonna find out yes and as we say that
you are you have so many amps in your
life you're a mother and you're married
and your music and the married and
unmarried you're not married
now I mean I'm with someone fine oh you
are for a long we have to elaborate on
the not married stuff later then anyway
sure and you're a mousse and you're a
model and co rad of this wonderful book
so welcome here to to the far north of
Europe to the darkness but Shakespeare
has said there is no darkness but
ignorance so the whole purpose of the
book exactly so we are so enchants what
an amazing connection yes isn't it exp
and you guys it's incredible it is it's
also so we are so pleased that you will
be here coming to McClay and teach us
how to be Parisians wherever we are
yeah at least you know give you three
yeah we have an hour you're right yeah I
said I'll share since we are also
celebrating that this oh it's such a
nice book you know I love books and this
book is so beautiful it's like it's a
hot bag it has a nice texture you have
the wide you have the red and the blue
you twinkle oh really
yes oh yeah I know you know what I never
noticed I never I not I honestly didn't
realize it was the French flag mr. Lumm
I said the medieval ambassador
so so so now we actually today
celebrating that it's translated into
Danish yes but we talked a bit about it
was never it never came out in French
why no I just thought it was a strange
thing to talk about
you know French people to French people
it was a bit how do you say redundant if
you know um I think it's fun to give
tricks to people that don't know us and
say hey you know I like to do things
that way you know you can try if you
want to have fun or if you know but it
was a bit strange to tell it to French
people
so it wasn't English was it to American
mostly or just oh no we're in 36
countries now 3633 translations yeah
yeah you guys are last I think no but
you know why because you you speak so
well English that the book came first in
English here and then yeah then some
other people ask to have it self so we
see multiple why have said that you are
you're not born a woman you become one
is that the same with Parisian actually
I believe so I believe so because the
most famous Parisian women are
foreigners like Jan Joaquin Charlotte
completing a mission there all those
women you know have learned in living in
Paris that I guess we'll talk about
later but that kind of freedom and
independence towards being a woman and
we have a little video should we show
the audience the wonderful little video
yes I've wrote I wrote ten little tricks
of being Parisian right away if you
follow those tricks you'll be fine or
not which is the whole idea let's have a
look I have it here too
Hey yeah I'm stirred the show man
backstage yeah yeah it was great I loved
it a public gallery the shape so there
were some really cool cuts and would you
meaning was crap
now you call it you have no idea when
you see the show online you can't tell
about it
you know I was there I saw you know I'm
still there I'm with the designer right
now yeah I was just telling him how cool
it was know it's going to change fashion
darling it's really a new woman that he
did yeah no it's amazing amazing
oh my god last night it was crazy
oh this guy's well yeah oh gosh what
what do you mean that called smoke do
you think it's dangerous if I smoke in
here Oh
I'm sorry it's just have so many things
to do and busy busy busy sorry
Americus of wine please
possible if it goes in Mac notice cuz I
circled I got it all day long
of course I'm a FEMINIST everybody
should be a feminist it's about equality
of rights it's human rights know what I
mean mm-hmm
and then you know what drives me crazy
the exploitation of the woman's image
you see like girls naked everywhere on
Billboard's I mean half naked you know
and it's all about sex life action
drives me crazy
you
melih voila that's it
there's so many contradiction in this
woman yeah
but we're free you're free oh great it's
pretty to to do whatever yeah I feel
like I'm allowed to be in a bad mood and
allowed to be in a good mood have Lisa
let myself be so so where does this
where does this
scruffy arrogant contradictive woman
come from I have a little photo I want
to show you so maybe we could elaborate
if it comes out I'm not very good Oh
oh shoot what's happening duh this one
the car that got returned oh yes yeah
you have any question about it yeah but
I think it's very beautiful because um
it is the price use right it's the story
about the pushers and no I I do think
that we are the fruit of our education
and knowledge and and yes the French
women has been raised on you know
literature in early pictures and and and
you know we were in salon already in in
the Lumiere yeah no talking in the
saloon with all the artists as well
there was there was always a romantic
and games between you know men and women
and and life and so I think we're raised
in that culture of playing yeah because
that is what the the map of tenderness
is it is you have to go to get to the to
the village of love you have to go
through all these difficult things is
that something while you were you
brought up with it I mean this kind of
game with a way to do all the way to be
did you hear from from of this from your
your mother or your grandmother no I
think it's quite unconscious yes we do
have you know where it's funny how
France is located yeah and Paris in
France it's we're really between the
north and the south and the west and the
East is like we really have that mix of
no more cold and a bit more feminist
from the north thank you guys you know
that you bring that to us but also that
Latin part that we have it's really a
mix and you can really fill it in the
way we behave and we are and and there
is this gallantry that I haven't seen
here because I had a door slamming my
face the first step I had at the airport
because I was just you know expecting
the man in front of me to hold the door
but that does not happen so yeah it's
you know it's always game of gallantry
but not making you feel like less of a
woman you know or or less power but it's
a game it's a game yeah it's really very
much about game isn't it yeah to find
the parts and know how to I and you know
and and find how to be a happy yourself
but also to please the other mm-hmm yes
accepting less powerful you're even more
powerful in a way could you control it
yeah limitations give you freedom
doesn't it really
anyway limitations gives you kind of
freedom yeah I mean no yes first at an
extent there's some art there's some
women that had inspires you Parisians I
think we should talk a bit about them
lissa moon here we have a herdsman there
yeah it's a very strong woman yeah I
mean you know she she gave us amazing
rights as women I mean for you it's
gonna sound very you know we're in the
70s right now I think it is what 70 74
75 she brought the right of abortion I
mean you guys were able to vote in 1915
I've read yes I think yeah I don't yeah
yeah I'm very impressed so you have
nothing to teach you that in this case
but yes it does those women that went
down the streets to to get those rights
for us as a Parisian I feel I have a
responsibility even style-wise and as
woman to respect myself and to in a way
being their path as not as an activist
but also just you know respecting the
woman they manage to to gain for us yes
and not be too light and I think it's
really fun to see women because the
perishing woman because she always want
you to think that she's an intellectual
in a way you know like she doesn't have
time to brush her hair and all these
things it's most of the time it's fake
really bad
it's an illusion creating an illusion
that she wants you to think that she has
so much more things but I'm Way more
interesting to do when taking care of
herself
yeah she's reading books and maybe also
reading about books oh this here we have
semen de Beauvoir purse aft ya know why
is the same kind of woman yes it is
really yeah opening doors for women and
and expressing her art and and
philosophy and you know yeah it's the
same idea of opening doors and then we
have the third C Mon C Mon C new I see
once in your head yeah so Monsignor a is
a big Parisian in a way that she's that
extreme lover that will give anything
for her relationship and I think it was
fun in the book to make kind of like a
story on the Simone's yeah and what's
you know what sweet about Simon senior
hey that she you know there was even
more Tom flirting with Marilyn Monroe
but you never gave a gave up and she was
always there to fight for her lover and
yeah it's it's you know it's funny how
we always enjoy the cinematographic
lives and and you know we have a
tendency to put ourselves into fiction
mmm
to make it more fun or trouble Oh
trouble yeah yes she fought for him own
town she did that yeah yeah yes so we're
these are kind of the inner I find these
photos here in the library because we
are in a wonderful library we don't have
to forget that and they are 11 million
photos so I found these I were busy last
night mm-hmm
but anyway these were kind of the
the inner inspiration for you but there
are also other ideals and I think you
have a very very fun a tech on this and
I want to read loud to celebrate the
Danish translation I want to find
something I have no idea how its
translated to know but now so all the
stuff you think suck it's not me hahaha
bad translation it's a very nice
translation I promise you I read the
English one and I've read the Danish one
and yet playing it wasn't bad did a nice
job thank you
so better yes I just have to 100 yes be
heroes be the best version of yourself
yeah yes I read in Danish find this Ella
Hartman TPS man for China say Coco
Chanel's moon on on soup mein Leben
heart may I add up put you through it
what fat is Allah the smoke appear
somewhat owning accumulation or some
helpful at for al aliyul per day as 14
assignable always told at him something
he can seek common then somehow Intel in
Lily our you'll see for the heat no mail
1840 cheaper solid brand awesome honest
my own some Kobe Ida sister has unfair
this rocket eclipse Canada
Danita ignore espuma most rotten man's
careful you may be very gooey molten
dibela accepted as in Ella and eager hey
no nella bhai if the heart linguist at
Patrick said knock teeth advocate
peroxide knocked it karma TSA Elka will
in the moose head nor weekly but say own
my own skin his keoki
diagon's give his known some leaders
vehicles Kubo talk selected men or
sentence Quran so as isolated off of the
egged and strict buffet ahankhah means
vez na [ __ ] ins and six I mean you get
a face without wrinkles but a face of
fear
aya yeah yes so we have to be courageous
why are we so scared of getting old what
is that oh because men don't look at you
okay so we become unfair woman yeah I
think I think that's part of the plans I
think I think addiction wise it's
becoming more difficult and people stop
turning around to you after a while but
a it's always very complicated that
question because yeah I was you know it
was quite lucky when I was born I was my
I don't know my face and no no man and
it's hard because I'm okay when I look
at myself in the mirror so I you know
it's not the same ID and and and I'm
very fortunate because I'm 40 years old
and I still have you know Chanel and
Lancome and people taking me pic taking
pictures of me so so it's very it's much
easier for me to age that way with
people saying oh you're still okay you
know even though you know you're not so
happy when you look at yourself in the
mirror and the everything starting to
fall apart
but it is easier for me so it's a it's a
strange position but yes I do believe
that globalization of face for everyone
is a bit sad and and and we should try
to live with what we have but it's not
that easy now it's not that easy but but
really this book is also very much about
liberation actually so you get real
iterated you have to liberate yourself
but you also have to kind of liberate
yourself from your age I mean then you
do liberated you get a certain age and
then suddenly then you can get to
suppress by being older that's sad isn't
it yeah yeah I think that's why it's
called the best version of yourself
yeah learn okay if that's what you have
you'll never get that perfection you
know it it just doesn't exist with this
you have to give up that's already one
thing we explained the book and don't
hide behind those excuses of trying
always to get to that point you still
have dreams and you still have you know
things you want to have access to base
just yeah it's just being okay with
yourself you're admitting your flows
admitting your anxieties and
whatever you have and just leave learn
to live with lemon and be better and and
and I have fun with all the wrong stuff
but as Lyon he says there's a crack in
everything that's where the light gets
in that's exactly right now there's a
crack in everything that's where the
light gets in so it's kind of being
transparent and open and have lots of
sense of humor with it yes yeah yeah
yeah I think and and and knowledge yeah
I think knowledge is a big part of the
whole thing and a lot of young girls
asked me about style yeah and you know
and fashion and how you know I became
you know famous or at least working with
the famous and stuff and I'm like my
style comes from knowledge from from
reading books from going to concerts
from going to exhibitions that's what
makes my personality which is going to
make the way I want to be and I want
people to see me and also I will have I
won't need as much as being in a
representation because the more you read
and the more you feed yourself the more
you see that they're much more
interesting stuff yeah and and and all
these become one character and and your
own self but you've also created a
career being that I mean doing what you
want doing your stuff being your age I
mean they would also prepare the way
format your women something yeah no I
was very lucky that that women
suddenly were ready to be represented by
older women at the same time as I was
aging that's that's pure chance and it
was interesting but but even though when
I was a young model I was not skinny and
I still managed to buy my personality to
turn around the system and be okay you
know what I need to eat I love to eat so
I won't be that model but I will offer
you something more authentic and you
know when we can take it and so it you
know it speaks to some women it doesn't
to others you know everyone
have their own people they can identify
- there are different speeds especially
right now
yeah we've internet and all the you know
social network and another different
kind of IDs of women representing you
Satan
yeah so intensity is really and you can
be yourself I think you're right that
the Internet can open up for its showing
around and showing yeah I mean I can't
do it otherwise anyway as far as I'm
concerned but I think I think people are
ready to you know to hear sincere
thoughts and and and see people with
life and you know so we now a master
class we have now we listen we take your
advice we have to read some books so we
won't be so focused on our looks
it's very good we in this library so do
you like libraries by the way what do
you use libraries in parents do you go
to library I go I do go along I do
yeah I go to leave him as a Haena which
is by the Institute of house in the six
I love because it's it's so it's such an
intense historical place that you feel
like you have to go to work you know
what I mean you feel like you have to
get to work it's not high literature I
have to admit even still it makes me
want to create and do things so I go to
leave a limousine great yeah so let's
talk about sex baby let's talk about you
and view exactly this is okay a very
sexy book yeah yeah it is yeah the
West's point is if we speak about sex
no we speak about our sexiness maybe
sexiness maybe outlet yeah you want to
talk about sex because you do talk about
sex I think there's so many good tips in
this on it's very inspiring
yeah that's why my boyfriend was not
allowed to read it
he wasn't enough to has he read it now
no no he's not allowed he's not allowed
to go over there tricks I don't want him
to know no of course not as what what
what what which there is one for example
about you know when you get into a room
and you sput right away the girl that's
gonna be a problem for your whole night
yeah
you're like okay this one's gonna be
trouble you know but so what you do is
instead of being jealous right away you
know and be like oh my god you know
she's dressed like a [ __ ] poor girl I
heard she was stupid you know whatever
yeah yeah you break his fantasy going in
his bubble saying oh wow look at this
girl you know he's a medic who like
right yeah and you go like yeah a nerd
she was bright and then a man she's a
credit becomes all like cheesy and stuff
and you really go into his bubble that
he can't fantasize anymore cuz if you
break the deal that is it's still gonna
be his stuff Wow yeah that's great
that's what I show you actually take the
experience out of it you read it you you
just you take it over that's a great
yeah it's a good trick yeah believe me
did you have no choice anyway no so
break the fantasy so it so it but it
takes some courage huh some courage
courage you know that no oh
is natural to me but but you also have
another another fantastic trick is how
to destabilize a man a lady should I
read it loud and Danish yeah sure if you
want to I I do because it's a wonderful
thing you just don't know it by heart
anymore no I never did but the Joel oh
yeah yeah yeah we get back to this all
right
Sarang go home in musica the healer you
say yes I'll tell it cuts the affair
epic lair men giggling for clang he
ended idea if the confer Taylor I'm seen
a feminine for deviating go after a sock
only thing they hinder tale I'm politic
me Morton or six my own he need I would
say Lysander not for who stood o Kesava
the earthly doughnuts no man spare in
verden wound hard here in the fact his
glamour as happy hope who I'm saman
hinder guard mood for a battle of his
village in indiscreet hunt for his law
hidden Allegra Hamlet Oz has a petite
miss sex nor vena Easter for tale armed
hindered equipment
Katia I'm gonna lend tab stupid-head
henna daffy know who they are for petite
lining for a noir hood her big Compton
Hin that you'd hate to fit it open it
oblique we pull the didn't smokers too
they immediately you don't know what I
read is it was and I do have an eighty
is all the products yes yes no it's
about it's what she's doing she forgets
to take on the she forgets to take on
the bra and the summer and stuff like
yeah yeah it's fun it's fun to play you
know to play with I think it's cute and
once again is putting yourself in
situations and a bit move easing and
it's felt like for example it's always I
always found it more interesting to have
you know a sweater that falls on your
shoulder because somehow I'm I'm
straight so I'll say the man but the
other person the man we you know we'll
we'll you know it's still a moment of
your of your shoulder or of your neck
which he thinks it's gonna be his moment
but you did it in purpose but you know
what I mean yeah yeah or your back or
something while if you just have your
cleavage I mean it's too easy you know
what you know what I mean is yes but
when they feel it's their own thing then
you know men are power everything Wow
that's why I so it's this belongs to me
yeah we have we have a Danish author who
once said I think it was Hammond part
that the Lumumba had no hair meant back
our name oh no it's a French politician
no no he's not very sexy yeah but you
don't have to win your know or anyway no
petition but he talked about you know
sexiness of sensuality as that that the
thought should get a glimpse of what the
I couldn't see exactly that's relates
it's erotic yeah yeah yeah from it's
exactly what I was exactly what they're
explaining in in nice words yeah in
nicer words
so we have to cover we have to have
these big sweaters and dropping down the
shot at us no issues no time just liking
something yeah it's just it's just fun
tricks yes a meal to play to play um but
there are good tricks yeah they're
french fries to play with do do a
Parisian sleep with a date on the first
night now a Persian does whatever she
wants to okay yeah I I mean they're
really they're not really politically
correct or incorrect stuff I think
embarrass we have a chance of being a
big city as well so you can of can yes
we talked about that de l'église yeah
yeah five millions like Paris with once
everything something wow how do you do
how do you find people and it's amazing
and and you're also beautiful kind of
it's strange scary yeah caressing France
you know five million people in the same
country we would all have like really
rare faces like an eye here and a night
there really you would be my sister and
my mother think of it and I'm talking
about mother the mother is very has a
fun
she's you mentioned the mother a lot in
the book you've got about the mother the
relation to mother what mother teach and
yeah yeah I think I think they're
timeless you know tricks and inheritance
from our mothers and and the way they
teach us how you know to be as a woman
and you know from how to dress to how to
respect yourself how to respect other
people and once again it's still when we
talk about mothers is still like we
talked about Simon day and when the
bagua is all these respect to to the
elders that opened doors for you yeah
this is really not about respect for
other generations and often when we we
we talk about family in Denmark it's
very much about the father mother and
two kids
it's kind of like that but in in this
book you always represent the grandma
the aunt or you know it's it's a bigger
family like that yeah yeah cuz it's you
know it's those people that came in your
life and gave you a hint of elegance are
a hint of feminism or you know are
talking about love there was all those
women in your life that would teach you
those things that build your personality
yeah and you have a very funny it's the
child as a satellite could we elaborate
a bit on that because that is great fun
well it's just that I really understood
as a mother that my child could not be
happy if I wasn't happy I need something
in my relationship anyway
yeah and so I think it's called self
you're playing with your toy
I'm playing with my toy I mean how else
I caught icon sailing healthy healthy
yeah I have a lisp healthy happy
selfishness healthy self you know what I
mean yeah and it's funny because the
other day I was in the plane and you had
this woman poor woman they still have to
do a yes and so they're doing this thing
and for once I'm looking at it and she
goes you know if anything happened put
your mask on and then put it on the kid
and I'm like it was awful you know
because that's exactly the opposite that
would do naturally and then he made
sense I was like it's true you know you
have take care of yourself to be able to
take care of others and that's a bit the
idea of this child that it is a
satellite is he leaves your life anyway
he's going to leave at one point so he
leaves your life you leave his life and
it's all a big yeah a bigger
merry-go-round
but it's also I think it's very we have
we have in in Denmark we talked about
lot about spirits mothers spent know
yeah but spit it's actually just wheat
and they did they made this marketing
stunt that spilt this kind of wheat was
a bit of wheat yeah we make bit like
when you big
and these spec mothers are getting their
children three o'clock in the afternoon
and do everything correctly and I really
think it's reliefing that to talk about
the saddle the the train oh yeah I think
I mean it's life I need to leave my life
I want to leave my life I want to live
my life with my child I want to live my
life is my not husband but boyfriend
right my life my career I'm going to
leave all this and it's fun I have no
guilt whatsoever in what I do I think
nobody should have guilt and I don't
think I mean I know that the time I see
my son is so much more intense because
I'm happy and and so and you know I'm
not tired when I see him and all those
things because I am doing what I like
and I don't know it I mean it just makes
sense for me but it is because there's a
lot of skills connected because and
guilt and perfection actually it
actually goes together that's why I see
sometimes that you want to be the
perfect mother so and then if you don't
get I think you'll all be perfect of
anything no it's good to let go and have
some fun yeah and have some fun I mean
it's really the idea let's try to
explain you have this very beautiful
idea of love for love's sake yes it's
like being financially independent yes
to only love for love yeah
yes well you know I I got lucky but yeah
I think you know if you can achieve that
it is kind of hard nowadays I know
because it's hard to you know to pay
your rent and on and on it's important
you need to share a lot of times but but
yeah and being independent as well
financially makes you able to live your
life and and that person you love just
comes in your life for the right reasons
you don't expect anything from them but
giving you some you know of some fun
time and and and you know shoulders and
things but you don't have any
expectations which which i think is the
reason why
I'm for 12 years now yeah quite cool
yeah nowadays it is and super never
happy in love but I won't get married
that you have a very another fantastic
trick is when if if you cheat upon your
husband how how to dream Ya Allah
that's the only chapter no no no that
that's the only problem in this book for
me before we wrote the book for people
and that part was very important to one
of the four we fought a lot
I screamed aloud because I do not know
personally any person who is happy about
it
and who would want it so so it is a
problem for me that chapter yeah because
I don't I don't believe in it it's the
only chapter that I'm like ah nobody
lets me let me read it and we can I'm
sorry I messed up the whole no you did
not haha no we aren't missing again love
love is the one where yeah it's another
one yeah yeah go ahead sorry haha
good so scared for beginner retina might
do skits be nicked play a guitar sent me
school fools to God if at I am Elohim
dick outfit I I got Vera conferred I got
40 powerful to answer to besieged by in
mal I'm so full Queen doing Eskimo a
given I as well as vana to capital R
teen madman to my igloo hum
hence air adhesive 80 something
personally wiggling lacked in else
Casteel folk nama EDT mobile on an hour
who can't Noba l elected Internet
investor Venice now moon heart only
illegal that are in him little sub a GPS
ocular seven comma X in France assist
not riskier schedule feel you great no
my its biscuit assail
Massoud army will carry some awesome
answer you don't tell auditorium did
matatini
the Palestine six men kill demons cast
behind Altadena else kasam demamp leave
our city w memo said aforetime Bulow Tim
elsker meeting men so tell me about it
yes I think you're right
the free love you can't live a delivery
right there but do we have I think that
lots of people have no no I mean most of
people do yeah but I don't want it no no
no but because what does it do it it
drones the relationship doesn't it yeah
I think I'm too much of a megalomaniac I
just I just want to be the only one
right what you're asking me yes I'm
curious because I think I have no wills
whatsoever to share no no but I think
because I think that a lot of people
think that in Paris of being a Parisian
is also about you know let Oblivion and
I think everybody cheats in the whole
world
yeah just more okay about it we just
yeah but everyone cheats yeah
so yeah it's a fact girls no no but yeah
I'm not you know really happy about it I
don't I had a problem with it you know
why because it's it's a bit of a French
cliche that's what I mean and the whole
book was made on breaking those cliches
and it was a new take on the Parisian
woman saying we're not perfect and you
think and maybe some woman in the world
inspire themselves on the Parisian woman
because she actually gave up on
perfection and she has this freedom
that's so exciting in a way of just
being and you know and she's elegant as
well but and so I don't want it - no no
no it's right yeah it's it is a cliche
it is a cliche it's not a cliche that it
just happens everywhere I don't mind if
any politician
you know I don't I don't want to know
their private life and I don't mind of
whatever they do with it you know as
long as it's not hurting but yeah it's
not my problem so that's I know that's
quite different in some other countries
like in America for example where you
know some president or it was a big
problem it I really don't care so I do
have this thing which is not a cliche of
not minding other people's business on
that case so we make it lucious that's
much better
illusion and games that's wonderful I
think also you talk about work as I said
before we in the library and read a lot
of books a lot of book references in
your books who you refers to lots of
authors writing about parents and stuff
and it's it's very funny because Henry
Kissinger
he said that knowledge is power and
power is sexy so the power character the
the book reading makes you more sexy
really yeah read the book no no I do I
mean we talked about it earlier yes
knowledge knowledge is power and
knowledge is sexy I mean that's what you
have more and more to offer to other
people and and and I mean for me it's
the it's the base of my life I'm I love
to learn I think that's what life is
about
and it's it's a pleasure it's something
yeah it's the base David Boies ed Fame
it's when am i and start taking things
over and you're very famous woman you
have 300 thousand followers on Instagram
what does that kind of power how can you
use it doesn't that give a
responsibility and how does it yeah well
first of all you become like a TV for
people which is very strange I mean I
understand that it's my story right now
here today but it's very strange when
people approach you and you're supposed
to divert them you know they look at you
like this and you supposed to say
something funny or something I don't
know it's very strange
that thing where people just expect
something from you but the rest is yes I
do I do have I I want to have this
responsibility of giving that this other
aspect of women which is more you know
of a women of mind I guess
we're talking about fashiona fit to the
line that you know - yeah to show girls
that they're much more than Fame and and
you know light and stardom and all this
and and to get to this you have to work
and I really believe in work and for me
it's one of the biggest virtual virtual
there's just a nurturing you know that
and and so that's what I try to explain
and and and this and feminism as well
but not here obviously but I do I'm you
know I'm I work with the Ong NGO called
yeah here where I'm specialized in the
education for women all over the world
so you know we create schools and try to
find ways of having them you know girls
that are not allowed or don't have
access to school you know to to all this
I try to have the brands that I work
with in fashion to invest you know money
in that what kind of things yes with
women in these women involved yes yes
yes yes was just you know human rights
yeah so so we have had a Fashion Week
here in in Denmark this week it's just a
sustainability and fashion do you have
any thoughts of that and it takes on
that one
sustainability yeah those are the
products a good made and yeah yeah I
mean yes I think I think more and more
brands start to get conscious on that
it's it's very difficult for me as a to
be in fashion and and you know and when
you have the way you think and then they
still make sense when you're in fashion
you know
you know there is a way of seeing women
and then ecology and all these things
that are you know sometimes it's a bit
schizophrenic because they don't all go
together no it's a hard work there to
make the ends fit yeah so but the lots
of brands that are getting better of
course in in luxury brands it is easier
because it's almost like creature in a
way where you know you know where which
cow leather pants from but um you know I
think people are getting more and more
conscious hopefully there is such a huge
industry that it's really hard for me to
stand strong I know I don't wear fur or
I don't you know but I'd still do a lot
of wrong stuff I try to I try to push
the people I work with to be yeah yeah
and and and and the girls as well to go
into more in a slow fashion and and is I
think the Parisian women understands
this is is is fine you know your
timeless pieces that are going to make
your personality and you as a woman and
it's much more interesting than changing
every day of clothes that are not of
such good quality and you know and and
you become the trend rather than you
know fashion becoming who you are yes
but you have you have lot of that in the
book you mean the old stuff you inherit
and I will share it a back that's old so
it things always have a history that
points back somehow
it's funny because people always talk
about our style as effortless yeah and
and I always say it's it doesn't mean no
efforts it takes a lot of it it takes a
lot of years to get to that effortless
look because it's you know you is just
you get the pieces that know that work
with your body with your skin tone with
who you are and how and the people you
want you know them to talk to you and
you know what I mean it's like you won't
get approached the same way if you have
if I would wear a miniskirt right now
and a cleavage
and it would be different which is any
would be good as well I love wearing
miniskirts sometimes but um you know
it's always together but maybe it's the
simplicity of this tile I mean that you
can look there couldn't be sexy in a
shirt that goes down on the shoulder
yeah it's always that that it's little
twists to find that extra button that
you open that you did up and today I can
see I did I read the book I mean yeah
we're like we're twins where did we need
to introduce yeah I'm gonna come back
here and everyone's gonna have to it's
gonna be horrible
is it give me all the same people I'm
good it's a very good is nobody I like
that talking about you know so this is
just an ability in fashion that you have
these key items that you keep a jacket
or stuff like that with a history yes
yeah yes and and and you know and you
add every season you find a few stuff
but you're gonna add but it's more about
it is it's more it's almost you almost
get a uniform of who you are there's
also some full pass yes yes
should we read the full pass yeah that's
so much fun they're funny I mean I think
we're funny I think they're funny - I
just had to find them the essential
version what'd you find black where is
the essentials I just had to youtube you
can't remember what page is is can you
you can't remember the page nope
I don't even know which photo it was
their own mind by the way am I took the
pictures this it's because it's a very
funny list on what the full pass what
you don't really have to have in the
closet I didn't find it yeah it's right
unless in English what patience is it
it's the same 40 40 okay
haha
yes I do wear glasses they're here I
can't see anything that's why I say you
all look great you're a liar
you may be mentioned that's great okay
bad taste is it cold
is it bad taste see that's that's a
wrong translation it is it should have
been full pass why yeah this is
different but it's fine oh yeah yeah
there is no judgement
nope that taste is a judgment that's
right a full pile it's just dude and now
you here spurn once infest a handy one
in a way our spare Hunter had Sheila
head boil up spilling stone family's
tomb so far contest at all our steamed
farm is it for Pliocene a tenth of a
mile in lost Rama Atticus's plug Cena or
in point formal via Deena Messina burn
visit demonstrative Amin ping man ha
Olivia faded grandeur some hits within
unschooling at Yahoo family drag four
fixes in labor some in Iran n they are
overdressed a vimana corpo fisk after
kobe makka moo moo diana management
floral some vxm his DNA
lavender to be a holy man service Calif
our test asset for elbow leads yes but
you also have something under wardrobe
that I thought was so much there's some
boots you're not allowed to to to wear
I'm good
yeah the boots you hate books boots
boots the ark boots oh yeah yeah I know
I'm after really sorry cuz I heard they
were like philosophers and amazing
writers that carry orange with a boots
on it's okay we forgive you it's also
this is there something that you know
really in Denmark
you use the word snobbish
yes we are snobbish I have to say yes
yeah okay elaborate oh I don't know I
mean that's just we yeah we have a
tendency to think we know it all it's
kind of true because now we all have our
own truth and mine is very strong my
agent is here I've been suffering for 20
years of my knowledge there's no [ __ ]
working about it it's because knowledge
is the worst thing you could be in
Denmark I mean we really have air Iman
oh try to to consider Landon yes we only
5 million you know it doesn't work to
stake out maybe that's the reason yeah I
don't know it's kind of fun to UM to do
where you're supposed to do and yeah is
a liberation isn't it I really feel that
this is you know this is a book on
liberation it is a book on having fun
it's a book of vision you know a woman
in yourself yeah living the life yeah
have a good time yeah it's really it's
it's really like a little you know those
little books where it's a bit like
champagne yeah there's little bubbles
that pop and you're like glue
I it was the idea you know it was to to
keep you awake and and try to have fun
and to learn and to and all this
together is it's just a more funny
moment than life and we have an answer
to everything in this book you have it
there's an answer to everything in this
book I mean how's it to throw a party
the Big Bang everything is good
everything I mean I hope they don't need
any more however we do there are lots of
yeah of the majors is love work
yeah no Jim no Geo elaborate on that one
why no Jim yeah it's boring yes it is
isn't it boy it's so boring it's
unbelievable I mean is crazy yeah
I wish there was this special pill that
you could take and did I call okay
yeah I do I have to say that I did this
year start in gym to now I did yoga
which is already hey so I do yoga it's
good I still hate the teacher when it
comes in I always try to hide in my
apartment I can sick it's horrible you
know not to do it I feel great after I
guess you know my body is more alive and
I have to keep it alive a I really hate
it yeah it's just the way this yeah it's
not our thing and it's funny because all
my friends are the same they hate it
true you you always end up at the bar
down the gym you know waiting for them
to come because you never go alone you
know good you know you always need
excuses so you never go along you have
to find friends to go with you so you
stay in the bar and skip the class then
yeah because the time everybody comes in
and you know I have you have to you know
there's all the stories of the week to
tell and then it's too late and so you
end up with a gym membership card that
has never been used you know that it's
like all your salary anyway but yeah no
no Jim Jim we walk we walk a lot in
Paris yes yeah so you know you try to
you try to balance it and by doing other
things
walking what's your favorite spot in
Paris my favorite spot yeah to walk yeah
by the river by the river yeah there is
something very animal or at least very
natural by the river where the wind
blows and you know it's a cross of winds
and first of all the view is amazing and
you have the sky and and all the most
beautiful monuments are all around the
river most of them and the and I don't
know all the wind and the water and it
just makes it all dramatic and you feel
like you have this crazy life there
walking exercise yeah
wow I'm walking I'm so like
but that's my life when you return we
have a little spot in Copenhagen by soo
Yun it's then the spiral almost look
like Paris yeah you can maybe have a
stroll there one day yeah I would live
your white life in Qom yeah I did yeah I
did from the car to here it was it quite
freezing okay and and then there was
this lovely lady with me saying hey you
want to go for a stroll for a few
minutes I was like no thank you
I'll go in um but yes I will um yeah so
definitely you know I love your country
that's I'm actually coming back with my
son yes and where you going with us to
Legoland yeah yeah you got a lovely
gonna yeah I know
I love playing Lego Star Wars Lego I
play I'm very active it's like IKEA I
became the chief of all those things
he's got you ever stepped on the Lego
barefoot yes I have yeah joy its own
Thea Pia what it's cold so it's actually
funny how a silicon dictator style isn't
it how was the city conducted a style it
7th yeah fun yeah I mean it's there many
reasons because of course you know
writing this book we kind of try to
understand why it was such an appeal to
other countries and and and first I
really understood that that the fact
that it was a socialist country made it
made us understand the value of the
artwork and rather than you know and
people would not dress in a other how
you call that you know bling-bling all
those things you know it's not another
country it is rather cool like vulgar
yeah to show to I think it I mean it's
the same here not to show your your
wealth it would be more in fabrics or in
the art craft rather than showing off so
I think that's a big part
getting dressed is entires
is linked to that it's linked as well to
all those women that open our path
so to stay quite strong women um you
know could you with born in France and
and it's the same thing you're
unconsciously raised in one of the most
beautiful city in the world where all
the arts are so are inhabiting the walls
you know and so you have I think you
really learn the elegance and the
respect of all this and you wanna you
want to be part of this of this beauty
in a way you know and that be a faux pas
however of it I think yeah and how is
Paris I mean 2015 was a tough year for
Paris yes yeah
how is it's doing it's a it's good it
was a it was very sad i think i think
it's a worldwide problem it doesn't a
it's an inherent in to paris i do think
that when you were such a special city
and the city of lights that attract all
this you know tourists and all this of
course it was a it was a good trick yeah
to to attack this one but Paris is fine
Paris Paris always comes out of
everything in a we're where life goes on
anyway what are you going to do and then
and in Paris is fine and is now of
course super safe and and fun and still
beautiful
so we have to turn on the light as few
experiences yeah
Oh
you